Thanks it's really a pleasure to be here
and really thank you very much Michael
for the invitation so I am gonna be
speaking about this book project which
is available on Amazon if you're
interested in purchasing actually so I'm
speaking about this work that that that
I did is it largely said as a
dissertation at Cornell as a PhD student
and one of the things that interested me
and when I first artist siting in the
Mars Exploration Rover mission was the
role of images on the mission team I was
captivated by these incredible pictures
that would come out and be on the front
pages of the New York Times or displayed
across some website somewhere and
wondering what role were these images
playing and the kind of work that
scientists were doing how did they make
them what what where do these images
come from and therefore how could we
understand where they went so when I was
initially working with a team I started
off as an ethnographer and I was on my
second day of fieldwork when I heard
somebody in the team said well you know
when you work with the team for a while
you kind of learned to see like a rover
and as someone who was interested in
visualization I was fascinated it's like
what could that possibly mean so over
the course of the next you know 40
minutes or so I'm gonna describe ways of
seeing like a rover that bring together
a couple of these really important
questions for human-computer interaction
and for computer-supported cooperative
work first of all how do people do
science with data visualizations and how
do they do science with robots how do
organizations matter to science and
technology and to user experience and
thirdly what makes for a kind of
technology that people love and I'm sure
for many of us who do design work that
that latter one is is really an
important point to do that I'm going to
draw on ethnographic work I'm not sure
who you've heard from in this series so
far this year but ethnography is a well
accepted technique in anthropology and
sociology and now also in human-computer
interaction anthropology was was the
field that started doing ethnography and
what happened was people would go off
into the field and they would they would
you know go to some remote island and
they would be like what are the natives
doing and they would write about what
the natives were doing and then they
would come home and publish a book and
that would be that we've come a long way
since then for a variety of reasons
but one of the one of the elements of
ethnography that's still the same as I
basically did that with scientists like
I went away to spend a bunch of time
with scientists what are the scientists
doing and then came back and was able to
write about that ethnography relies on a
series of different techniques and
practices including interviews including
participation to some extent in the
practices of the mission I worked as an
image calibrator I interviewed something
like 80 different members of the team
from the undergrads working on summer
projects all the way up to the people
who were running the mission and people
who worked at NASA
it meant visiting in this case 10
different sites that were affiliated
with the mission because this is a
remotely operated vehicle obviously
nobody is on Mars but also nobody's
entirely at NASA
these are scientists and engineers who
are spread out across a variety of
different institutions around the United
States
so getting to visit those different
areas and I sat with scientists at their
desks while they manipulated images and
tried to see new things and do science
with the pictures that came back on Mars
and I sat in on almost 500 different
meetings of scientists and engineers
sitting together and trying to decide
what it was the robot should do the next
day on that other planet so this was the
this is the kind of data that I am
working with and will be speaking about
today I should also tell you a bit about
the robot that I'm going to talk about
today or the robots that I'm talking
about because there's been a lot of
missions to Mars relatively recently and
a lot of public imagination about Mars
and how many of you have seen the
Martian so far yeah okay excellent
so there's lots of different ways in
which Mars has captured our imagination
the robots I'm going to talk about today
were launched in 2003 they arrived in
Mars in 2004 there are two of them they
both were identical at the time of
launch one was named spirit and the
others named Opportunity Spirit
unfortunately passed away in 2011 if any
of you would like to hear about the
robot funeral I'm happy to answer
questions about that in Q&A including
what you wear to a robot funeral because
as an ethnographer that was a that was a
challenging question an opportunity is
still exploring today it's been 11 years
is still working on Mars so there's a
couple of things that these robots can
do and a couple of things that they
can't do and this is really important to
preface the talk the robots were
designed as robotic geologists because
they're looking for evidence of past
water on Mars and geologists have a
pretty good way of figuring out how to
do that they're equipped with a variety
of different cameras 9 and all - they're
amounted at the top of the the very top
of the mast the two large ones are the
panoramic cameras these are the ones
that have color capabilities and they
tend to produce the really beautiful
spreads of color images that you see in
the newspapers there's also cameras for
navigation that can provide a sort of
wide-angle view
there's specific cameras mounted under
the solar panels in the front and the
back of the robot that have a kind of
fisheye lens they take in a much broader
view so that they can detect whether
there's hazards in there in the way of
the robot so the robot can drive around
it and there's a little hand lens one as
a microscope the robots also have many
different spectrum eaters on them so
they're taking spectral readings of the
rocks around them and they have this
little piece of equipment out here that
will allow them to scrape the the
coating off a rock and see what's
underneath so those are the kinds of
things that the robots can do but
there's a lot that they can't do they're
not incredibly bright they have they
have some artificial intelligence but
it's incredibly limited what this means
is if they are driving along and there's
a rock in front of them they know that
they should not drive over that rock of
course a huge problem on the mission was
if if they then know that they should
drive around the rock are they going to
end up going in the same direction or
are they going to drive around the rock
and sort of end up over here so that was
one of the main artificial intelligence
tasks that people were working on at the
time of the road that the Rovers were in
operation so they can't actually do a
whole lot the other thing that they
can't really do is they sorry yes so
they're not human next so the robots
because of the the distance between
Earth and Mars there is no single
operator with their fingers on a
joystick with their hands on a joystick
there is no individual operator who's
responsible for what's happening on Mars
and because it takes seven to 20 light
minutes for a signal to get there you
can't actually do anything in real-time
so instead what happens is a whole
community of scientists and engineers
who are responsible for not only
thinking about what the robot should do
scientifically but also what it can do
practically in terms of engineering
concerns have to meet on a daily basis
and decide exactly what that robots
going to do the next day and they get
together and they come up with a
detailed plan that then gets uploaded to
the robot at one go so I'm on the robot
wakes up on Mars it gets its
instructions from Earth it goes and does
those things and then before it goes to
sleep it sends the data back and the
people on earth wake up they get that
data and then they try to figure out
what it should do next so that's what a
planning cycle looks like so the robot
is not making decisions autonomously
it's not working autonomously it's very
very limited artificial intelligence
very limited autonomy autonomy
capabilities
sorry how long is a day a Martian days
Lauren Mars day is 24 and a half hours
very good yeah very close but so when
they first initially worked on the
mission they worked together at JPL and
they worked on Mars time so that means
that you start your meeting at 9 o'clock
in the morning it's 9 o'clock on earth
and of course the next day it's 936 on
earth and before you know you're meeting
at 2:00 in the morning or you're getting
off shift at like 6:30 in the morning on
a Sunday trying to get a beer in
Pasadena turns out it's hard to do they
don't tend to work on the Martian clock
anymore they have ways of sort of
working out the time difference between
the two places but they're very much
aware of what time it is on Mars and
versus what time it is on earth where
the robots are also the robots are on
opposite sides of the planet so they
aren't working together they are very
far far apart so what when you
communicate with one usually typically
you can't necessarily communicate with
the other so that's a little bit about
what they can and can't do so I'm gonna
come back to this notion of seeing like
a rover and describe three elements that
I observed on the team that are part and
parcel of learning to see like this
robot first of all is a series of
digital visualizations and digital
manipulations of images that allow you
to see like the robot does and not only
do science but also make decisions about
where the robot can and can't go
secondly I'm going to describe a series
of embodied relationships that people
have with these robots the kinds of
physical instantiation of the robot that
they take on in their own body and this
is the part that gets really really fun
and then the third element is the part
that I argue you need to have as a base
to understand why these why they're
behaving the way that they are and that
is the question of social organization
so I'm going to bring these three things
together to unpack what it is to see
like a rover let me start with data
visualizations so seeing like a rover
first of all means learning to have an
appreciation for the native views that
the robot sends back from Mars so the
images here are taken by the hazard
avoidance cameras these are the ones
that are perched under just looking over
the wheels under the solar panels and
they enable you to identify if there's
any hazards in the terrain and they have
this fisheye lens because they're trying
to take in a much broader you know
expanse so they can actually do
something with that they can actually do
something with the data that they
acquire so and and this is really funny
because when this image when
just like this first came down this too
often some of the first ones to come
down from Mars apparently there was a
reporter in the room at the time and he
was like oh my gosh Mars is really
different it's super curvy they were
like no it's not actually Zurich RV it's
the lens right that's doing that but
interestingly it would be super easy to
correct this in an image processor I
mean you just press like a single button
and you could turn it into something
that looks more like a rectangular frame
that we are used to looking at with
human eyes but they almost never do
almost never
when these images are presented instead
scientists will talk about the kinds of
ways that they had to learn to see these
images one of them described using an
image on the your right which is the one
that was taken before the robot flew
saying I need pictures like this on the
right to make the kind of correction I
sort of get a sense in my own body of
what it is like to see this way and
another scientist whenever he puts these
pictures up in a presentation he's like
just remember objects in the mirror are
closer than they appear so this is a way
of first of all demonstrating that you
have a members oriented way of
understanding Mars that is you are a
member of the team you start to become a
member of the team when you can start to
see Mars this way in the way that the
rover does but it's not only about being
able to see natively like the robot it's
also a question of being able to do the
kind of data visualizations and
manipulations that are going to allow
you to see into wavelengths that the
robot can see that you can't so here's
an example of some turf topsoil at an
area where spirit had gotten stuck and
the scientists were analyzing that the
the the images of the soil because it
turned out that there was this white
soil that was like underneath the
Martian the red stuff on top and the
Martian terrain and they were trying to
understand where where it came from and
what it was it turned out this became
one of the most important discoveries of
the mission that the area had once been
in ancient hot spring much like
Yellowstone but when I talked to
scientists about these sorts of images
of Mars that are all you know red and so
on he was like look we know Mars is red
like that we just know we get it seeing
more natural Mars colors doesn't help
I'm not gonna learn anything when I'm
learning something that's what I'm
seeing Mars and false-color now I'm
learning something new so the way that
you create these false color images is
not to sort of meticulously paint them
in my hand instead what you do is you
take pictures that are taken through the
robots different filters in front of the
camera lens and you combine those
filters in ways that don't correspond
with the sensibility of the human eye so
you put them through a red green
blew sort of color set in order to in
order to produce this color but it
doesn't relate to the human eye and in
fact that is seen as being much more
valuable because that way you're
harnessing the way that the robot can
see and not necessarily the way that
people can see and this is a sort of
side note here I should note that these
kinds of visualizations occurred across
the mission over and over again and
there was never a sense that there was
one best way to see Mars there were only
lots and lots of ways of working with
these images and seeing different
elements of the terrain at different
times and as a scientist put it when
you've seen Mars in all these different
ways then you get to know it so it was
never a question of what's the best
picture although obviously when you
start sending things out for public
release you think very carefully about
what it is you're presenting but instead
of many of these images circulated
behind the scenes in a variety of
different forms also presented in terms
of graphs and so on and it was never a
question of epistemological certainty of
like this you know the graph is a better
way to say it and see it and not the
image okay but it's so you don't always
want to see Mars in color sometimes you
want to see it in 3d particularly you
want to see it in 3d if you're
interested in driving the robot because
you'd like to know if there's anything
that might trip your robot up so
scientists would take an engineer's
would take pictures of the robot had
taken from the right eye and the left
eye and put them together into what it
would be a 3d anaglyph and this was long
before the days when you could like go
see the Martian in 3d the people would
have these 3d glasses they would wear
around the lab and they described it how
that when you take a look at it in 3d
different things pop out at you right
you can see that the terrain pops out of
you it's kind of undulating I could kind
of see there was a ridge here before but
now in 3d I can evaluate this better as
an obstacle so there's a couple of
things that are important here one is
not only that you're able to see things
in 3d but secondly that you're able to
evaluate things as obstacles and
obstacles are not obstacles for people
and they're not scientific targets
they're obstacles for the robot here's
another example this is a composite
image that is taken using hundreds and
hundreds and hundreds of images were put
together to make this one picture what
you're looking at at the base is a
picture taken from orbit top down of the
edge of a crater you can see the rover
is that little grey dot at the top this
is taken by the Mars Reconnaissance
Orbiter overhead what was happening was
the opportunity where they wanted to
drive opportunity down into a crater and
be able to drive opportunity back out of
the car
which is an imperative right you want to
get your robot in and out and in order
to do that they needed to figure out
what the slope was the different areas
in the crater to figure out what the
right way was to get in so they drove
the robot around over several months to
different areas or promontory Xin the
crater and took tons and tons and tons
of pictures loaded that all into some
software that graduate students were
busy writing and tweaking and eventually
came out with a kind of topography of
the terrain that was used by comparing
images from different locations kind of
like a big parallax problem right but so
here's what's fascinating they created
this contour map and the contour map is
the kind of thing that you would think
geologists would get very interested in
particularly around craters but in this
case it was not a contour map about the
actual values of things that the craters
it was really about where it was safe to
drive or where it was not safe to drive
so this is kind of the rover's eye view
of what that crater would be like it
certainly does represent scientific
values but the values that are really
important are the degrees of slope that
are going to trip up the robot so here's
where we start to move into from these
visualizations that try to take on the
rover's point of view and the Rovers
body is starting to have stories and
narratives and gestures that connect
your experience on earth to the robots
experience on Mars as one of the
engineers put it one of the important
things to know is about how the rover
sees the world while it's driving this
is really important so what the Rovers
field the world one is driving is like
your view of the world if you imagine
yourself trying to make your way through
a dark cluttered room with nothing but a
flashbulb so what you do is you kind of
take a picture and then you close your
eyes and you go along a little further
and then you take a picture and then you
go with your eyes and so that's the way
that the robot sees the world when it's
driving this is obviously important for
the rover driver to have a good sense of
what it is that robot is doing but
notice how what he does is link the
robots visual practices and the kinds of
pictures that he's going to receive on
earth to then the kinds of things that
the robot is going to do on Mars but
people had a variety of different
stories that really connected the robots
experiences to human experiences and
this is where things get really
interesting and exciting people would
talk about the robot having a sense of
touch that when it used its rock
abrasion tool most was feeling out the
rock and you could read the kind of
graph that resulted about the kind of
pressure that it was using on the rock
as a way of understanding the way the
robot was touching the rock so they
would get that sensibility in their body
your eyes sort of become the navigation
camera or the panoramic camera and some
people just said simply you know what
I'm working with these robots I am a
rover I should know that this is very
different than anthropomorphism right
although anthropomorphism does happen on
this mission so either for morphism is
when we project human characteristics
out onto the machines that were working
with and in this case what
anthropomorphism was very visible in the
fact that the Rovers had very different
personalities so opportunity is the
glamour girl opportunity just goes to
Mars to find water and she falls in a
hole and opens her eyes and bam there's
evidence of water she's the white collar
Rover she never had to work a hard day
in her life she was born with a silver
spoon in her mouth
that's what Opportunity is like whereas
Spirit is a little more hard-working
she's more hard-nosed this is the blue
collar over this is a little Rover that
could she gets to Mars and there's no
there's no evidence of water anywhere
and she just to drive really really far
to get there she's not the kind of robot
who's gonna go 300 million miles and
then give up right instead she's the
kind of robot that's gonna persevere so
these are the sorts of stories that are
told about these robots and we're part
of animating their personalities behind
the scenes but it's not simply that we
project human characteristics out onto
those robots really the kind of work
that I'm talking about here is the kind
of work where people would take robotic
characteristics also and bring those
back onto themselves on earth so I
started to see this in a variety of
different forms that yep go ahead
projective characteristics of the two
Rovers almost preordained on a mission
or was it really by all of these
glitching things that happened along the
way in fact I think the reason which is
before this is where it's really hard to
disentangle do the robot stories come
the personalities come about as a result
of those stories I mean perhaps to a
certain extent when you when you listen
to these stories you do hear the story
of the team persevering you do hear the
stories of the robot breaking and the
team kind of figuring out how to work
around that and the robots seeming to be
a bit obstinate but talking to the
principal investigator about this there
was a moment at the
funeral where he he was talking about
the robots personalities and he said you
know when you when you when if you were
there when they were born and they
started to move and behave and take on
personalities and I was never able to
let go of that you know even this far
into the mission I was never gonna let
go that so there's a sensibility in
which the robots have a kind of
personality from the start and the way
that the robot sort of handled things
along the way reveals different aspects
of that personality so it's um it's a
really tricky thing to try to work out
they certainly weren't encoded with
personalities before they left that's it
yeah okay so so there's a series of
things that people would do that I refer
to as a kind of physical calculus and
this is a way in which they would use
material objects around them in order to
make sense of the digital visualizations
they were getting and the digital
signatures they were getting from the
robot on Mars so here's an example where
there's a an operator using the camera
she for the camera for the rover she's
trying to figure out how to take a
picture of something that's very close
to the robot or as she said between our
feet so not her feet but actually the
robot's feet and that's a very
complicated task is aware and how the
cameras going to point so what she did
was print out pictures of what was
around the robot and sort of laid them
out on that computer screen as if it was
kind of like the area around her around
the robot and that was how she was able
to make sense of where and how the robot
should be pointing so taking this out of
a digital realm and into a physical
realm before she's able to do that
calculating work and put it into the
software I have certainly witnessed
people using wheelchairs in order to
sort of work their way through robot
encounters in another really interesting
case related to the panoramic cameras
people would put post-it notes on their
foreheads at the beginning of the
mission which sounds completely
ridiculous except that the pan cam
operations software will show you a
picture of the the scene and then you
you did you tell it where you want it to
take a picture by putting a little
yellow square over it a yellow square
much like a post-it note right so people
would put these post-it notes on their
forehead and kind of make this list
relationship between what was happening
on their bodies and what was happening
on the screens and then what was
happening on Mars and certainly
engineers would talk about how when
they're training nude Rover drivers you
can tell that they get it when they can
start using their own arms when they're
talking about a robotic
with the arm they picked their arm up
and move it just so or they start moving
their bodies in a particular kind of way
another engineer that I spoke to
described how he was a long-distance
runner and he said you know you know how
when you go for a really long run you
know how you're gonna feel the next day
you know you're maybe gonna feel a bit
sore the next day well I know that with
the rover if it's gone for a really long
drive or something I know what its gonna
feel like I know what its gonna be like
tomorrow again a sensibility in his body
related to the kind of work the robot
was doing so some of this didn't just
happen on the level of material
practices but it also started to happen
on a level of gesture and embodiment
that I was able to observe across the
mission I'm gonna show you a brief
pretty video clip and I should note that
this video was not captured in the wild
it was a it was a moment when I asked
one of the instrument operators to
please demonstrate some of the things
that I'd seen people do around the lab
repeatedly and using their bodies to be
like the robot and note in this in this
example how she talks specifically
through and then uses her body to show
the ways in which she connects her own
experience on earth to the robots on
Mars
okay so my body is always the rover
hears in front of the rover here's my
magnets and here's my solar panels and I
would see people in talks or you know in
certainly there's one moment in a talk
where this one guy was like remember we
were doing this thing with opportunity
we were kind of over here and then we
sort of went over here a bit and we did
this one and he got up and he was like
wait a minute Janet where's your camera
I'm totally doing it right now and they
would literally move their bodies around
in this particular way now there's a way
of thinking about this as if it was a
gesture of communicative practice it's
one thing if we're once I get one thing
if we're in the room together and we are
like okay so we are you know interacting
and I'm gonna be like let's move the
robot's arm this way right that would be
one thing but these are people sitting
in a teleconference room like by
themselves maybe with an ethnographer in
there with them but they're they're
talking into a teleconference system
there's nobody there to see them move
their arms they're working that through
in their own bodies as they're
describing the different things that the
robot might be doing on the surface so
yes what images have this what is there
be a major excited that the robots give
you a moment that kind of you know the
kind of moments the robot arms can make
probably it might end up being very
different from what yes
in Arkansas there gas stations well
right well so not necessarily using it
to specifically calculate out and said
it was kind of again the physical
calculus notion is a way of thinking
through how do people do the quick sort
of like the quick thumbs in their head
the kind of notion in their head of
whether or not this is going to work on
Mars or not and so they would have this
they would rely on this very intuitive
embodied sense of what the robot would
do in order to do things so actually the
the opposite side of that is that it
actually enabled them to do some really
amazing things on Mars they and enable
them to push the robot in ways that no
one had ever intended so no one intended
the robot to use its own arm and use the
Microsoft camera on the own its own arm
to look underneath its solar panels and
be able to detect whether or not it was
stuck on a rock I mean no one had ever
expected to do that no one had ever
expected to drive the robot up at the
kinds of slopes that it did know
whenever there were several things that
they managed to push the robot to do or
use its wheel to crush to crush rocks on
the surface and then take pictures of
that it was never designed for any of
that but it was part of that embodied
sensibility of what the robot could do
in their own bodies that they're like oh
hey
couldn't we just kind of crush this a
little bit interestingly to the the way
that you related to the robots own
bodies changed as the robots bodies
underwent some changes on Mars as well
so about 400 days in 600 days in spirits
wheel stuck it got stuck and actually
part of the reason why they managed to
turf up that white soil was that the
robot was stuck in the sand trap and it
was kind of driving back and forth and
if you've ever tried to push a shopping
cart with a stuck wheel on the front you
know that it's actually really hard to
do that right so the engineers gradually
figured out it was easier to drag that
shopping cart so they just started
driving spirit backwards so for a while
there it was like oh my god are broken
Rover it's terrible it's broke here this
is really horrible
and then they started realizing once
they realize that that it was that stuck
wheel that had turfed up that light soil
they stopped calling it the bum wheel
and they started calling it the
trenching tool right because you could
just drag the robot and you could create
a trench as you did that and take
pictures of that and do science with
that so in fact the embodiment actually
gave them more flexibility not because
they were doing actual calculations but
because they could they could use their
bodies to work through what the robot
might be able to or might not be able to
do but things do get a little stranger I
mean also
point to some ways in which the robots
body becomes important in a couple of
minutes but things do get a bit stranger
and that it's not just that we get an
embodied sense of what the robot is
doing in our own bodies but we might
also rely on stories about what the
robot is doing to make sense of our
experiences on earth so here is a quote
from a scientist in her 50s that I
interviewed she said you know it was
really strange I was working in my
garden one day and all of a sudden I
just my right wrist to stop working out
of nowhere I like I couldn't use it I
got to the rover meeting the next day
and spirits right front wheel was broken
that's why my right wrist stopped
working right because I am totally
connected to that robot so in case
you're like well that's a bit weird and
maybe it's because she's you know female
or a scientist here is a young
30-something male engineer you know it's
funny I screwed up my shoulder in
Taekwondo and I needed surgery on it
right around the time when opportunity
shoulder-joint stopped working and I
broke my toe right before spirits will
broke so I don't know I'm just saying
maybe there's probably not any magic
involved maybe it's something
sympathetic I'm not really sure and
certainly working on the mission you
could tell I guess people were walking
down the hallway from the sound of the
the pea I always wears the cowboy boots
and you could hear the sound of his
heels on the on the floor outside you
could tell if it was a good day on Mars
or not certainly when there was a dust
storm in 2007 and opportunity was caught
in this dust storm people would hunched
over at their desks I mean they've made
their bodies small they talked about how
it was like having a grandparent in a
hospital on you and you knew that the
doctors were doing everything they could
but you would just all you could do is
just sort of sit there and hope that
they would make it through so these
kinds of like sympathetic relationships
with the Rober went from just trying to
understand what it was the rover was
doing to make drawing this direct
connection to what it was the robot was
doing on earth and that's why largely
when people would talk about their work
they would say I when I'm doing this
work I am a rover so how do we make
sense of that as a sociologist in the
laboratory watching this happen
it's on the one hand it's quite amazing
to see people use their bodies this way
and use these stories but the other hand
you're trying to figure out does this
serve a purpose within the context of
the team or is this just some kind of
weird thing that people do when they're
confronted with robots
so to
to answer that question I have to zoom
out a little bit and tell you a little
bit about how the Mars rover team works
as a team and here's a snapshot from the
the in-house video feed which is one of
the main ways in which people knew how
to communicate or we're communicating
with each other at the time so what you
need to know about the Mars rover
mission team is that it is led by a
single principal investigator with a
flattened hierarchy so that is as a
group of scientists and engineers who
work together it's up to about 150
people at any given time but they are
all arranged much more laterally than
vertically so there's still a hierarchy
there's still a pie at the top but they
are but they all work together around
this robot the P I describe x' the robot
is something like a Swiss Army knife
it's a single tool but it has multiple
different capabilities and you can bring
any of those together to solve a problem
on Mars this is very different than how
NASA normally flies missions normally
they say we're going to go to Jupiter
who wants in and a whole bunch of people
apply to have an instrument on there and
NASA selects which instruments go on the
mission and those instruments go on and
they have a team of scientists that work
with that instrument on earth and
they're not allowed to work with any
other instrument only with the
instrument that's on that spacecraft and
they have to compete for the time and
the resources in the spacecraft now it's
important to note that spacecraft only
have so much time they only have so many
bytes of onboard memory they only have
so many bytes that they can transmit in
any given time to earth they only have
so much power in order to do the kinds
of observations that people want to do
so it's a highly resource constrained
space it's sort of like being on a bus
with 150 people where there's only one
steering wheel and only one camera and
you can kind of only take like three
pictures a day and you can imagine that
for the scientists and engineers on that
bus or on that robot they have a variety
of different things that they would like
to do and they have to figure out how to
decide exactly what the robots going to
do one thing at a time so it becomes
something of a micro political problem
behind the scenes how are they going to
make a decision this is a team that has
embraced the concept of consensus
unilateral consensus is the way that
they make decisions and they don't have
time to go into all of the processes
here but I'll mention that there's a
variety of different forms of talk
resources and technologies that use in
order to support this Corian tation
towards consensus the main meeting
happens once a day for each robot it is
an hour long and as in that meeting
scientists and engineers review the data
that came down from the robot the night
for and they try to figure out what it
is the robot should do the next day one
of the chairs of this meeting explained
to me that the whole goal of the meeting
is so that people at the end of the
meeting feel like they have a sense of
ownership over this over the plan you
want everyone to feel like they're part
of the process
see you later explained it's the whole
empowerment thing they need to feel like
they're being listened to and like
they're part of the process so it's not
there's no voting there's no I want to
do this and I'm more important than you
but instead that the whole process of
working together is one of making sure
that we are constantly working together
you'll notice that even on the
videoconferencing screen it might look
like nobody showed up for work that day
because all of these seats are empty but
actually what this does is is a visual
reminder that all of these people are
phoned in on the teleconference line and
you need to be able to agree with all of
them at the end of the meeting and you
only have an hour with which to do so
now interestingly at the end of the hour
they go around the room virtually on the
teleconference line they ask everybody
on the line are you happy and everybody
has to say yes I'm happy
before they proceed and you should try
this at your next faculty meeting let's
try it you know because it's super easy
and actually it's um I jest but it's
actually what the joke reveals the fact
that you can't just go to the end of the
meeting and be like are you happy you
have to have worked the whole way
through to make sure that by the time
you get to the end of the meeting people
are happy and you have to use a variety
of different tools and resources in
order to do that so one of the resources
that they use is actually the Rovers
body itself like the concept of this
embodiment wrote embodied relationship
to the robot becomes very important for
achieving that kind of consensus behind
the scenes as one of the operators have
said to me look to be fully prepared for
my job I need to literally be that
vehicle that's what all that
visualization software I use is all
about right cuz for me you have to
intuitively make decisions you have to
get questions on the fly and you have to
answer them on the fly and so you're not
you you're the rover I think of myself
as the rover so I can call the shots I
need to know where I am is the rover
it's a huge huge part of my job so seen
in that light in the context of this
meeting where you need to come to
consensus those kinds of physical
activities and physical calculus and
that embodied relationship with the
rover doesn't seem so strange because
it's actually part of your job right to
be able to do that images also play a
really important role in producing
consensus as well so here's a case where
a false color image
being circulated among members of the
team and a scientist really wanted the
rover to drive from over here where the
rover is sitting taking the picture to
like over on that side of the over on
that side of the screen and in order to
do that he needed to be able to show
that the rover was gonna be able to
drive there effectively that he'd be
valuated these things as obstacles and
the slopes and made sure that it was
going to be okay so first of all II put
it in to false color because in false
color the rocks kind of pop out at you
so you can tell exactly where those
obstacles are remember that whole thing
about evaluating his obstacles and then
he draws this line here and says this is
a minimal Ridge remember the slope map
this is minimal we're going to be able
to drive over it and it's gonna be okay
and then he puts it up and he says look
you showed one on-ramp to this area
called home plate this is a team that
loves baseball I'm happy to answer
questions about that later on
I had to learn a ton about baseball to
understand what they were talking about
you showed this on ramp to home plate
that did look unapproachable or
difficult but what I'm wondering with
these images is an alternative that I
wondered if you'd looked at as well so
he puts us out there on the
teleconference line and an engineer the
rover driver comes back and says look
we've looked at all those southern
approaches and we just don't think
they're viable we don't want to get
stuck somewhere that we can't recover
now one of the divides that might
potentially happen on the team is
between scientists and engineers and the
team is constantly working to integrate
and to achieve consensus so that
division between scientists and
engineers is one of the things that they
constantly all have to overcome and
they're deeply attuned to so this is
really like a little mini crisis moment
behind the scenes because a scientist
wants to do something he could seem like
a rover thinks that it's going to be
possible and the engineer is like I just
don't think we're gonna be able to do
that so what happens this is a classic
move in a consensus-based team another
scientist speaks up and says here's an
alternative if you can't agree between a
and B choose C maybe this one's gonna be
better instead and he starts parsing it
out seeing like a rover right it looks
very approachable it's smooth looking
he's already starting to evaluate
obstacles in the way and eventually the
team decides that's where they're gonna
go so they have this kind of talk and
these kind of images that are used
behind the scenes in order to generate
that sense of consensus I'd like you to
notice one other thing and that is the
use of the pronoun we and here we
doesn't mean we the engineers are we the
scientists it means we the rover and in
fact behind the scenes the one pronoun
that was used over and over and over
again to describe the robot was we so we
are going to turn around and take images
from this rig
we are going to we are four meters away
from that outcrop we want to image we're
going to bump forward we're going to
take these images we're going to do etc
not necessarily we we the rover and
something of a royal we right it's like
the rover and the team the team is
complicit in everything that the rover
does so an images like these would also
play a really significant role there
because what you can see is that you are
sitting in the position of the rover
right we're seeing like a rover we're
using one of these has cam avoidance
images and it's being drawn up to show
you what kinds of things you're looking
at and therefore to help you come to
consensus about what the robot should do
next so in this case the body of the
robot the use of that we becomes a
resource in the politics of consensus if
everyone is occupying the same position
at the same time the body of the robot
it becomes easier at the end of the day
to get to that happiness moment right
because we start from the same place so
we can end at the same place now to that
extent the the body of the robot is
incredibly important for forging that
relationship among members of the team
that enables them to come to consensus
and to that end it becomes very
interesting to think about what happens
when that body is no longer there so in
2007 to faulty commands were uploaded to
spirit and within a row basically within
the same week and the project basically
ground to a halt they were like hey stop
this is terrible we've got it we've got
to reevaluate we're doing this sent to
everyone home for the weekend they're
like go see your kids go for a hike go
do something else on Monday we'll get
back together and we're going to talk
about this because how is it that we as
a team could have made these mistakes
and put our robot in jeopardy so they
came back together on Monday morning and
there was this huge great I mean the
room at JPL was absolutely full the
teleconference line was full everyone
had phoned in from all over the country
and even all over the world and they had
a conversation about what they thought
they could be doing better what they
thought they could do differently and
one engineer said the following I
thought was interesting I get the
feeling that new team members don't have
the fear that we had at the beginning of
the mission it's more of a video game
for a lot of people it's kind of cool
it's abstracted a little bit they might
not be as connected to the fact the
rover is only one day away from we're
never gonna hear from it again and
anything we do could potentially ruin
the whole game so
one of the things that he's doing is
critiquing the way that new team members
haven't exactly learned yet how to see
like a rover they haven't learned to not
only be able to evaluate the terrain as
obstacles but also to bring that into
their own body and have alongside that a
sense of a relationship to the team
instead they're coming in having played
in this case doom mostly because I was
back in the day are you playing those
like first-person shooters and they have
this very particular view of computer
vision right of the way that we would
interact with a computational
environment that's being presented to us
in a visual way and in that way like if
something happens if you die you know
you have a 1-up you start again you play
it again there's no one up there's no
there's no start over there's no do-over
if you die the whole team is
disintegrating it's not just that you
lost the robot you've lost everything
and that's the way you're supposed to
work with these images he argues you're
supposed to be able to see in these
images not only the robot moving around
on Mars but also have that that sense of
the weightiness of the whole team riding
on your shoulders
to that extent anthropologically I would
borrow from the old-school work in
anthropology and sociology
about the role of the totem the role the
totem object and that is that the totem
is an object to which a tribe or a group
feels like they have a very strong
connection not only because that wrote
that totem is a representation of that
group but also because how that totem
fares has some kind of relationship to
how the group will fare and this is a
very old idea in anthropology but what's
interesting is to see it alive and well
today on a 21st century spacecraft
robotic team where there is a sense of
how the robot is faring is deeply
connected to how the team is faring and
that working together as a team is one
of the ways of sustaining that robot and
vice versa and this has really summed up
in some of the ways that team members
spoke about their robots as as a totem
as like a way of having a connection to
each other as well the hardware is like
the glue that Bond's the team together
while it's being built on Earth and that
time we could directly relate over
something physical but once the
spacecraft is off the ground that
connection moves into the software realm
and also into our minds so I would argue
the dynamics of the team took on greater
meaning what Spirit and Opportunity left
the planet because once those Rovers
leave Earth the team is all we've got
so those techniques of being able to see
like a rover being able to feel and move
and gesture and be like a rover are all
connected also to this success of the
team so I've argued that in order to
operate robots on Mars that scientists
and engineers are bringing together in
this very complicated way not only
visualizations and visual manipulations
but also this gestural and embodied
relationship to the robots experience on
Mars and finally they do that in a
particular social context one that is
oriented towards a very unique and
particular model of teamwork that brings
people together around this robot and
that that's what we should really talk
about when we talk about learning to see
like a rover and I'm going to close by
bringing out three or four implications
I think are important for human-computer
interaction more generally and the first
is that going back to this notion of the
plurality of these images that there's
no one best way to show these images
they're not like this is the best and
the only way to show Mars but instead
that when you see it in all these
different ways then you come to know it
and I think there's an important
implication there for the way we think
about data visualization particularly in
an era of big data when there's the
ability to transform images over and
over and over again to have different
visual inroads into very large and
complicated datasets and that they're
you know I know the whole Tufte
phenomenon is one of being able to
produce something that's beautiful or
that's inspiring as an image that will
help you Intuit your way through the
data but perhaps another way of thinking
about this is to think about the
plurality of representations that we can
have of those data systems and that by
transforming it in a number of different
ways to see different elements in the
scene that way we might get to know it
another important element from this from
this study is that bodies are an
essential part of working with
visualizations it is not only that
visualization happens with eyes and
screens but it happens with bodies with
hands with I am a rover etc it happens
with material elements that are being
assembled around those screens in order
to make sense of what's happening on the
screen sometimes those are bodies and
sometimes they're pieces of paper
printed out and if we lose the ability
to pay attention to those material
objects we're going to lose a very
serious and important element that we
could be designing around and with
thirdly that I think what's fascinating
about this example is that we can have
very rich interaction with robots that
don't look anything like us at all
we could have very complicated stories
about who they are and what their
personalities are and how we might
relate with them and have a very strong
emotional attachment to these robots
without them looking like us at all and
in fact to a certain extent what that
relies upon is not it's anthropomorphic
qualities but instead the organizational
context that one of the things I would
argue and that I've started to see in my
more recent studies with NASA is this is
a very unique way of relating to the
robot and to a certain extent it's not
unique if you think about it from an
organizational perspective a kind of
flat hierarchy with a very integrated
team and one that's focused on consensus
it's not surprising to see totemic
social relations emerge from that sense
so to that extent the kind of
relationships that we have with this
robot are predicated upon that
organizational context but what that
means is that in order to think about
the ways in which our technologies are
going to be used we need to think not
just beyond the desktop but beyond the
single user and the single technology to
think more about the organizational
context in which these technologies are
embedded now that could be if you're
designing something for a hospital right
if your robot knows how to take a like
blood pressure and how to give a
painless shot or something like that but
it doesn't know that it should pay more
attention to what the doctor says than
what the nurse says that robot is going
to be dead in the water right so there's
lots of right it was a variety of
different ways of bringing in the
organizational context of the work that
we do but what that's going to mean is
using these particular kinds of
ethnographic and interview techniques to
move away from those desktop to move
away from those one-to-one
human-computer interactions to think
about that much more in the context of
the organization so I'd like to thank
you for your attention and I welcome any
questions thanks Fred yes yeah let's you
become a part of the team yes Dirk I'm
all over the place
yep see you about the ways in which
people feel effervescence even in the
absence of a machine to orient their
bodies in that direction hmm and so when
I'm kind of wondering about is is how
important our bodies in the production
of effervescence in technological
settings can you do it without the sheen
at the center that you have to see like
can you imagine yourself yeah really
good point I have to think about that so
I haven't studied open source
communities although I know a lot of
people who work in them I would say that
even if the body doesn't necessarily
matter other kinds of materiality and
material cultures do matter so it may be
that the platforms that they're working
with or working through play some kind
of a role I'm thinking about Karen norsu
Tina and Earth's bruger's work on the
market as an object of attachment like
people who work as financial traders are
producing the market even as they're
seeing it and they're constantly in this
this this kind of entrainment with their
with their screens and they talk about
the market is kind of being everywhere
and all around them even though they're
sort of Co producing it at the same time
so I would still expect to see like
those kinds of social effects and
certainly belonging to a community of
open-source people who are who span
across the world can be a tremendously
invigorating an emotional kind of
experience certainly knowing many of
them at like my brother is a Drupal
programmer write-ins is my gosh you
can't say a bad thing about Drupal at
all in front of him ever right because
and that's like taking down the whole
team I would also say that there are
other kinds of totemic or symbolic
relations
you know the Linux penguin etc I mean
there's there's symbols that we might
use in order to delineate ourselves as
members of a community or not but I
would still look for those kinds of
material instantiation x' and then i
would look at other elements of
embodiment particularly with respect to
code in what ways are we attenuated to
what if it's a market the kind of market
system and what ways are we expected to
use our bodies in order to code what
Weiser would expected to be you know up
until 5:00 in the morning drinking Red
Bull etc that's pretty much an embodied
experience as well it might not be one
of like this right but it's certainly a
very particular kind of body that's
expected to do that and a particular
kind of training is suspected to do that
so when they meet each other my net when
open-source engineers meet each other
like you know not only was i working
until 1:00 in the morning of my real job
and then I was you know fixing this bug
until 6:00 and it and they had these
kind of war stories about that and I
think that's a really important part of
membership in the community just as much
as knowing that this is how the robot
moves not like this you know is also
part of membership a great question was
the fact that Cornell professor and all
helped you get into this or is that just
that well sure I mean one of the main
ways I was able to get it was actually
because I was affiliated with Cornell
and this was important because
spacecraft are subject to international
regulations about trafficking in
armaments because spacecraft are
technically weaponry and some classified
sense knowing things about spacecraft
systems is classified or is restricted
only to American Nationals and it's only
within a university context that
actually you can't discriminate based on
national orientate or national on any
kind of orientation but certainly not on
nationality so there was a certain way
in which being at a university was
almost the only way that I could start
working on this on this mission and also
because it was more focused on the
science and not necessarily the
engineering and in the book I talked a
lot about this that because of that
issue about national restrictions the
engineering was very much off limits for
me and in this kind of observation I
could really only work with the
scientists I could talk to the engineers
and I certainly did but I couldn't sort
of sit in the meetings while they were
actually coding what goes up to the
robots that was off-limits so being at
the university was important being at
Cornell was also important but I would
say like access is not a single one-time
thing it's an evolving thing and it's an
evolving conversation at this point I've
been involved with planetary science for
ten years and basically I started ten
years ago and my interactions with them
have been predicated on very different
kinds of respecting over time so while I
worked on the rover team I also worked
as
image calibrator which was great because
in the one hand it was interested in
images and how you produce images and
how you produce trustworthy images to
sort of be somebody who's like in the
pipeline making that happen was part of
the study but it was also you know some
of the implications that came up with
were things that the the guy who ran the
cameras then ended up implementing as
part of a way to improve his team I
think also it's worth noting that
there's a group in HCI at NASA Ames and
they had done some studies of the
mission in the early days especially
when they lived on Mars time and
everyone had these like Mars watches
that were 24 and a half hour days and
and apparently it was crazy so they had
some sensibility to what HCI looked like
what CCW looked like what this kind of
research looked like but that
conversation about how you might
contribute to the missions changes a lot
over time and it kind of it's not a t1
it's a t TN plus one kind of
conversation yes you come out see it
like the computer game yeah join this
mission little later they might not feel
like they belong in this group of people
who are very much associated with the
robot while the robot no way yeah
and if you any rituals that help people
be normal because we know so much about
how be you knowing uncertainty and even
negative outcomes yes yeah well one of
the rituals I think that very much help
with belonging at the beginning was
being in an Abbe was at the very outset
was living on Mars time so as much as
everyone talks about how much they hated
that period they were basically
permanently jet lagged for three months
right so it was not the most fun and
when you think about ever when you think
about those like you know consultants
that come in and want to do like you
know trust training in your organization
and they they get people to like stand
up and like fall over and everyone holds
on they basically did that for like
three months when they lived on Mars
timely because you're constantly falling
over and hoping that your colleagues are
going to be there to help you sometimes
like physically and literally so that
was a really strong I don't want to say
bonding experience cuz it sounds it
sounds much weaker but it was an
incredibly strong experience for members
of the team a kind of set of ritual
interactions that really brought them
together two years and they brought in a
new set of team members they had a new
open competition and they brought in
these new team members by the time I
showed up on the mission you really
couldn't tell the difference between the
pneuma team members in the old ones some
of them had seen the
robots like quote-unquote in the flesh
before they had left and they they but
the way that they had learned to move
and see like a rover or use their bodies
like a rover where were transferred to
or transmitted to new members of the
team so I almost couldn't tell the
difference when I first came in if there
was a distinction between the newcomers
and the people that had been there for a
long time and I found it took about a
good six months before I also started to
feel like a rover in my own body before
I started to know what it felt like to
be spirit versus opportunity because
they feel somewhat different you know
spirit has a the wheel and Opportunity
has this weird sort of shoulder join you
could kind of get a sense in your own
body of what that felt like to be the
robot so it took a good about six months
before that really came on as part of
the embodied practice but if there were
any specific rituals that were involved
I think actually learning to move your
body like the robot was a very powerful
way of belonging to the team and I also
realized that later on I had an article
that was published in an HCI journal and
they wanted to illustrate it and they
were like this is great they came up and
they had this illustrator and they drew
pictures of people moving their bodies
like robots and they sent it to me and I
was like this is terrible it looks
nothing like the rover dance like this
is not at all what they do you know cuz
they had people doing crazy other things
they were like oh but it's just an
artist's impression and so on and it
really revealed to me how much there
were very specific ways of moving like
that robot that you were supposed to
acquire that really marked you as a
member a good question but Watson okay
did you have any prop of the robot or
like you know the fake robot same size
is something that could be present the
movements and so each so how did that
map was what they were doing anything
didn't have for that I've changed their
interaction it's a really good question
they did have some props almost everyone
had some like you know Lego robot or
maybe not Lego but other like sort of
micro machine or some kind of model
robot that was sort of available but
they kind of sat in the corner they
weren't really used most people didn't
really pay attention to them they were
kind of you know they would get
decorated like that robot that had that
pin saying that it was two years old
because that was spirits second year
birthday on Mars
so they didn't have those kind of
instantiations but they weren't used or
referred to as a way of trying to
understand how the robot was gonna work
the one exception is there is a third
Rover and it is on earth and it is at
the Jet Propulsion Laboratory and it has
its own little sandbox and you basically
use it if you're trying to work
something out that's kind of complicated
and weird and I remember finally getting
to a chance to see that robot in person
and it was a very weird experience it
was almost like a disembodied experience
it's like meeting yourself right like it
was a very weird weird thing because I'd
been so used to seeing things from that
Rovers position along with all these
other members of the team that to see a
robot in the flesh was a very strange
thing now that said the robot was
usually imitating the things that the
robots we're doing on Mars or we're sort
of working through what their robot
might do on Mars and I do remember being
at a meeting or being at a went into
that room at one point and someone was
she was she was talking about the work
they were doing the robot it was when
spirit was was almost almost dead spirit
was dying and they were trying to figure
out how to get spirit out of the sand
trap that it was stuck in it had been
stuck also on top of a rock so it was
basically almost impossible and they had
this robot and then the sand pit and the
robots kind of listening to one side
like this you know cuz it's gonna set up
like spirit on Mars and here's this
woman talking to me and I noticed she
had a brace on her leg and I'm like gosh
what happened to your leg she's like I
had this freak salsa dancing accident
like I don't know I was kind of weird
I'm like really when did that happen
she's sick you know I was around the
time when spirit got stuck so so in a
certain sense seeing that robot on earth
like this and then she's kind of
standing like this was another kind of
physical representation of that
relationship but they don't tend to use
them that much now then I moved to
another mission to a different side of
the solar system one that's more
bureaucratic when it's a more
hierarchical and much like a completely
different social organization and they
have models of their spacecraft all over
the place and they use them to
physically you know move through how the
spacecraft is going to work and that's
part of the coordination work between
these different between these different
sub teams on that on that spacecraft
team but I didn't see anybody have the
same kind of emotional energy or anxiety
around their robots in the same way that
happened on this team yes oh so you
versions of this environment
get on the back that the robot that it
wasn't automated right you you had very
specific very difficult things you had
to do you could only take pictures it to
compile some data so you really had to
like think like a robot CIA the little
kind of snapshot that the robot got and
if you ask me before you know this talk
it would it have been better if the
robot had fully automated I would said
oh yeah I mean the room I could just
walk around and do whatever and we
didn't have to step through all these
obstacles but you also mentioned that
there were advantages once you've had a
body meant that there was like things
that that you thought of that you
couldn't have thought of otherwise and I
was just wondering you know in general
as we as we automate technology this
will make it better in your experience
what kind of things do we lose when we
sacrifice the embodiment of manually
using this tool as if it were you know
an extension of ourselves yeah it's such
a good question because I think actually
a lot of the expertise is in that
embodiment and it is in what we would
call sociological a tacit knowledge the
stuff that's not able to be communicated
specifically or explicitly but it's
actually part of the work of getting of
of knowing in your body how to do one
thing or another so in those classic
examples brushing your teeth or riding a
bike but I would argue it also applies
to the robot I think what's interesting
about these robots and their limited
capabilities is that they it's a certain
extent they're limited they don't think
like humans they don't move like humans
but that's also their advantage remember
the scientists saying like I don't want
to see Mars it's red I want to see Mars
in all of these these wavelengths that I
can't see you know so for many of them
you know it doesn't kind of suck that
the robot can only do so much at a time
and it can't drive very far like yeah
and if they were out there on Mars they
would be doing differently but many of
them also talked about the fact that the
the robot was their advantage right
because it was so different than humans
it could see things that humans couldn't
do it could do things that humans
couldn't do I mean one thing go to Mars
and that was the advantage one of the
things I think we lose when we think too
heavily about as a promoter fising
robots and and this is a you know
obviously there's longstanding critiques
of artificial intelligence this way but
it's thinking about the things that week
that that robots or computers or agents
or BOTS could do that are like what
humans can do and it's way more
interesting to see them do things that
aren't what humans can do because the
way the humans then make sense of that
and interact with that and kind of
create this sort of symbiotic team is is
what goes way beyond what a human could
do or even an intelligently augmented
human could do
I mean I think not only do we lose
something if we lose that if we move
away from that embodied relationship by
totally automating things I think the
risk of automating is the risk of losing
what's actually important about what
these robots do and what's important
about how they interact with humans so
the the automation impulse is clearly
like alive and well in many different
ways but I think often we automate the
wrong things or we've not paying
attention to these elements such as
gesture and emotion and so on like that
kind of teamwork if we just automated
the robot without the team how would you
do any science how would you do the
collaborating so I think that's where
thinking more carefully about automation
is going to be and about how we can
create agents that do very different
things in humans and put them in really
complex situations with humans is going
to be way more interesting and way more
exciting Thanks yes whirring wait does
or if so when does the embodiment break
down presumably the system gets
sufficiently complex I can't do this
anymore anyway grounding - so have you
seen it get to that point and do you
have to go to external aids like the
South Bend Commission or or is it just
we're operating in some new space that
one good example which I haven't got to
study curiosity my curiosity's arm works
very differently and it's huge and it's
beefy and it's massive and so there's
kind of a question of how do you how do
you create a sort of embodied
relationship with that robot what would
that look like given that it's it feels
like it's on such a different scale from
the human one and I think the place is
where that's interesting to look at is
when the robot breaks down right the
fact that spirits wheel did break and
opportunity's shoulder did break and
what happened was not that you know in
some cases people arms broke but what
happened was not that they were then
unable to be that robot but then they
would sort of incorporate that
brokenness into the way that they were
the robot so that I don't know if that
answers quite your question though
okay if it had he arms each of which had
like lots of different I suddenly it
becomes difficult it you can try to
project what it might be like it becomes
increasingly difficult it's like you
talked about like throwing it do more
like Mario or something very simple set
of rules that's easy to that's some
point you hit this uncanny valley where
like you know to get more more realistic
well you know my guess about that and I
don't I haven't seen this empirically so
I'm not sure this is actually an open
question and someone in this room should
do it but my guess would be that
actually the gestural and the embodied
will become even more important the more
distant the robot is from the way the
humans are very direct because it's a
way of sort of bridging that gap between
the between your body and what the robot
is doing so ironically the more strange
the robot is I think the more important
that materiality will be now that may be
like if the robot has you know eight
arms and and million degrees of freedom
that we're not ever gonna be able to do
that in our own bodies but what we do do
maybe we do this like what gestures do
people do in order to be that robot and
how is that embedded in them in the
organizational context of working with
that robot what physical objects the
physical calculus is a great example
right like that's printing things out I
mean people talked about having sheets
of like collections of sheets of paper
or books that were a certain weight
because it would help them get a sense
in their body of what the what the
pressure was that the rock abrasion tool
was applying you know so they they had a
variety of physical helps and I would
look at those physical material objects
in order to see what those relationships
are and again to get back to this
question about automation of course you
could go into there and be like well
this is going to be you know the
paperless office or you're just gonna be
able to intuitively understand this
robot you're not going to need any sort
of physical helps at all if you sort of
design that out of your space you might
have designed out the primary way that
people are going to connect with that
robot and with each other so you mention
early on that they did not define the
images that they were sending that the
robot
and I just cares here more about the
reasons behind that I mean without an
intentional empathy kind of decision or
was it I mean they got a lot of those
they have hundreds and hundreds of
thousands of those images so to a
certain extent it's kind of like a scale
problem but then you could always just
run it through an algorithm as soon as
it hits the ground they would do other
kinds of transformations with them
though because you know one of the
things that you needed to figure out was
the the topography of the terrain so you
would often use multiple different
images to create a mesh of what the
terrain looked like and then you would
not only use that for the for the
topography but then also overlay that on
top so you kind of have this very weird
stretched image like moving undulating
over terrain that you use those same
images to figure out what that terrain
was does that make sense so I would see
them get transformed in those ways they
would get used to compute a topography
and then get used to sort of lay over
the topography but I very very rarely
saw them corrected to a rectangular
frame and I think I think some of that
actually ended up being related to these
membership practices in a way that
wasn't necessarily intended from the
beginning because they're engineering
cameras like why do would you bother
looking at the engineering cameras but
turned out it ended up being a
relatively important way of circulating
them on the team of interacting with
what the pictures of robot took from
Mars so unintended consequences
you